okay welcome everybody so I hear it's
the playoffs I love it six wild card
games six chances of nuts in my family
so where's the uh Bengals fan no one
told him he'd come two years in a row
huh at least the Pats got eliminated
they used to be intimidating and now
they're a laughing stock you guys are
like the Steven Seagal of the NFL dude
I'm glad we're not in the playoffs it
gives us all this time to add 200 more
screen passes to our Playbook a whole
NFC East made the playoffs but me so it
looks like the uh Niners fan isn't in
therapy probably because he's the backup
quarterback so the Eagles are the
favorites to win the Super Bowl this
year huh if you predicted that at the
beginning of the Season you were either
drunk from Philadelphia and that's
redundant Philly fans love eating horse
and by that I mean Pats and Gino's not
gonna sit here and pretend like Jalen
hurts isn't a good quarterback they all
know he's gonna play for Washington in
10 years I really think Jalen hurts can
win the Eagles championship as long as
Tua can come in for him at halftime
right now we're all Bills fans so
heads up folding tables feels like the
road to the Super Bowl goes through
Buffalo but that road is impassable
because there's like seven feet of snow
and yeah I mean especially Canada but
with uh hot sauce and ugly people
there's a lot of hostility here today
doc I'm not gonna be cheap and call Tom
Brady old but I'm just saying that the
pirate ship and the Bucks End Zone will
stay there Transportation when he came
to the league Cowboys are heading to the
playoffs with some of that real Game of
Thrones finale energy dragons well no
the ending sucked no but seriously which
coach is worse flying Southwest or Mike
McCarthy 2023 that's Zach Prescott's
interception the completion ratio right
I'm not gonna make fun of that Cowboys
they have so many former stars like Troy
Aikman and Emmett Smith and Dak Prescott
the Jacksonville Jaguars and the
playoffs oh
that's all I got Giants making the
playoffs feels like a Madden glitch does
anybody remember them winning a game the
Giants are in the postseason but they're
not a playoff team they're a great coach
and arena league roster so the Vikings
won the NFC North with a negative Point
differential that's like the NFL
equivalent of winning the presidency via
the Electoral College TJ Hawkinson looks
like he works for the Vikings as their
logo oh my God Chargers fans couldn't be
more excited about being in the playoffs
and I should know I've spoken to both of
them wow it sounds like you guys all
hate these players and teams are you
even gonna watch the playoffs
oh my God okay